Oh, I laugh at even the INSINUATION
SINGE HERE!
that you think you're better than me!
I'll jack slap the back of yo ass out of your head, boi
if you even think you can come and get me!
Well I mean I could put up a fight if I-
you know, actually stood a chance against someone as gud as youuu
mlemmlemmlemmlemmlem
[mlem intensifies]
Ah, SIR
HAH
HEH
HOH
HUH
Um, how 'bout we take this outside
and then settle it with fisticuffs
like real men would
and then you'll SEE who's gonna fight the BEST
EVER
[snobbish laugh]
You wanna mess with me?
UHAHAHAHAHA
Anyone seen my glasses anywhere?
They've gone missing and I won't rest until I find them.
Someone's got them and I don't much appreciate this! [barely understandable]
*muacks* You wanna get a taste of these luscious lips?
Oh, I bet you do!
Do you like my long neck and strong jawline?
Bet you ain't never seen a handsome fellow like this before in your life.
Oh you have?
Oh. Well. Then.
I guess I'll just...
I'll be on my way.
Don't mind me!
I'LL BE ON MY WAY!
I'LL BE OUT OF YOUR HAIR IN A SECOND!
[???]
HUEHUEHUEHUEHUEHUEHUEHUEHUE
Peter.
Peter. (X2)
Get your lawn clippings out of my yard
whatever the fuck Joe Swanson says
Peter, you gotta listen.
Peter.
You can't do these stupid reckless things.
Well gosh, Joe *laughs*
This is the best face that I could get for Peter!
*higher-pitched* Well gosh, Joe!
HAHAHAHA Peter!
HAHAHAHAHAHA
Doc, give it to me straight.
How much longer do I have to live?
Everyone stop!
[sniffsniffsniff]
What's that smell?
[SNIFF]
Smells like...
... CRIME.
AUHAWHEEH
HEEEH.
HUH? Say it to my face!
Will you go to the prom with me?
Huh? You wanna mess with me?
You wanna mess with me, buddy?
You wanna mess with THESE lips?
(weird sounds)
HYAKHYAK
You don't think I'll mess you up, boi? Huh?
YES. I am HOOMAN.
Not a GLORGON.
I am having a HOOMAN face,
with HOOMAN hands.
Don't you see my HOOMAN ears?
And my HOOMAN nose?
It is very good for smelling HOOMAN smells.
And especially smelling BLIFNORF.
I love the smell of BLIFNORF in the morning.
Oh! Hey, what's that over there?
Aww, it looks so cute!
Is it gonn-AWWWW it's got my nose!
AH! AH! AH!
*squeaky voice* AH it's got my nose! AH!
AHHHHHHHHHHH
... Oh.
Well it's not so bad!
It's pretty good!
Hey Jeremy, come on in here!
Give me a HEY!
Give me a HO!
Did I hear...
that someone was making fun
of my tiny mouth
AGAIN!?
I'll kick their asses!
I see dead people.
'Scuse me, sorry I'm very uncomfortable
oh I'm sorry I'm sorry I didn't mean to go there
oh I'm sorry I'm so sorry
I'm here with my dawg.
Long Dog *muackmuack*
BARFBARF! Chica: ....
[devolves into uncontrollable laughter] Chica: dad are you ok
[red-faced laughter]
Hey Chica, what's wrong?
What's going on, Chica?
Are you DISTURBED by any of this? Chica: *eye roll*
Hey little momma let me whisper in your ear. Chica: ......
Oh, look at that smile!
Oh, look at that award-winning smile! Chica: *smiles*
Oh no, she's frowning now!
[even more laughter] Chica: *sigh*
[Chica still confused as Mark continues to laugh]
[Chica: Dad pls stop laughing into my ear]
You look so grumpy and sad!
But that's not true, right?
She doesn't like it when I touch her ear.
*pfft*
[more laughs] Chica: dad pls stahp
*pfft* Chica: STAAAAP
[moar laughs]
Oh my god, Chica what happened to you?
Chica! Chica no! Chica: .........
Chica! Chica: WHUT
Oh my god! Chica: *mlems*
[Chica mlems as Mark loses his mind once again]
Aww, turned into a tiny Pomeranian.
*high-pitched bow-wows*
Turned into a bunny!
Chica: *mm yess*
[yet more laughs to be had]
[Chica: Can I return to chewing up your house now?]
Mmmm yes I love it when you blow on my ear.
*pfft*
Mmm, yes indeed...
Say hi to everybody! Say hi! Chica: Hi everybody
Boopity-boopity-boopity-boop!
Boopboopboop!
Hi puppy!
Hey puppy!
I love you!
*muacks repeatedly*
Okay, I'll let you go now.
Okay!